mesdames messieurs bon dimanche c'est la
fête des mois que la vie en Haïti ne
fait qu'empirer les gangs de rue ont
pris le contrôle d'une bonne partie de
Port-au-Prince la capitale est de
plusieurs régions du pays le
gouvernement lui semble paralysé
incapable de contenir la crise les
Haïtiens manquent de carburant de
nourriture d'eau potable les commerces
les hôpitaux sont fermés ou fonctionnent
au ralenti les autorités sanitaires
craignent une explosion des cas de
choléra le gouvernement haïtien et le
secrétaire général de l'ONU réclame
l'intervention d'une force armée
internationale mais qu'en pensent le
Canada j'ai posé la question à notre
ambassadeur en Haïti qui est
actuellement de passage à Ottawa mon
entretien avec Sébastien carrière
immédiatement après ceci
[Musique]
le 7 juillet 2021 je venais le Moïse le
président d'Haïti est assassiné dans sa
résidence plus d'un an plus tard il n'a
toujours pas été remplacé c'est Ariel
Henri a fermenté Premier ministre enfin
l'attentat qui est à la tête du pays le
fragile gouvernement qu'il dirige est
incapable de contrôler les groupes
criminels qui opèrent principalement
dans la capitale ils ont la menise sur
les grandes voûtes autour de
Port-au-Prince et surtout sur le
principal terminal pétrolier du pays la
population terrorisée manque de tout
près de la moitié des habitants est au
bord de la famine et le choléra qui
avait posé la mort de 10 000 personnes
avant d'être jugulées en 2019 en
récemment refait son apparition le
gouvernement haïtien et le secrétaire
général de l'ONU réclame l'intervention
d'une force armée internationale pour
stabiliser le pays le Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies débattra de
la requête le 21 octobre
[Musique]
Sébastien carrière ambassadeur du Canada
d'Haïti bonjour merci d'être avec nous
bonjour
les choses sont mouvementées dans le
pays où vous représentez le Canada vous
y êtes depuis un an qu'est-ce qui a
changé depuis votre arrivée aujourd'hui
parce que changer c'est qu'il y a eu
quand même une détérioration importante
au niveau de la sécurité on a eu une
crise similaire en avant dernier avec
le blocage du terminal pétrolier de
vareux en avant 2021 suite à ça ça s'est
stabilisé mais vous savez les gangs
criminelles qui entourent Port au Prince
on continue à se rapprocher et raffermir
leur contrôle des banlieues immédiates
de la capitale on a aussi eu beaucoup de
dialogues politiques dans les 8 à 10
derniers mois qui a été fortement
encouragé d'ailleurs par la communauté
internationale le dialogue politique
interne c'est poursuivi malheureusement
pas porter fruit donc on se retrouve
en septembre octobre 2022 avec une
dégradation importante de la sécurité
essentiellement les gains de contrôle
les entrées les sorties de la capitale
donc tout autour de Port-au-Prince il y
a la mer depuis ensuite toute une série
de gangs qui contrôle différents
quartiers ça a commencé il y a un
environ avec le blocage de Martissant ça
c'est la banlieue sud ce qui est
extrêmement problématique parce que ça
empêche l'accès au sud du pays où on a
eu un tremblement de terre meurtrier
l'été dernier mais là c'est blocage là
c'est son propagé tout autour de la
capitale dans la dernière année comment
est-ce que les populations s'en sortent
on a l'impression quand on c'est
absolument c'est tragique quand je suis
arrivé ici on dénombrait 4.6 millions
d'ici en état d'insécurité alimentaire
le chiffre qui est avancé aujourd'hui
par la cour d'entrée humanitaire des
Nations unies en Haïti
c'est énorme ça c'est de la sécurité
alimentaire il y en a pour qui c'est
pire encore que de la sécurité
alimentaire absolument il y a des
populations complètes qui sont
terrorisées par ces gagnants dans
certains quartiers on parle souvent de
Cité Soleil les événements qui ont été
rapportés en juillet mais c'est dans
toutes les banlieues de la capitale le
kidnapping aussi des Haïtiens des
haïtiennes se font kidnapper c'est en
baisse depuis quelques mois mais c'est
après avoir une montée spectaculaire des
cas dans les six premiers mois de
l'année on fait quoi pour régler ça
écoutez c'est une problématique
à long terme à court terme et avec entre
les deux aussi un peu de moyen terme
dans la mesure où la communauté
internationale le gouvernement d'Haïti
doit d'abord rétablir la sécurité pour
ensuite espérer revenir à l'ordre
démocratique la Police nationale d'Haïti
a fait du bon travail dans la dernière
année ils ont eu des hauts et des bas
mais pour le Canada la solution problème
sécuritaire d'Haïti c'est la Police
nationale d'Haïti le Canada beaucoup
investi non la formation de la police
nationale beaucoup au cours des 10
dernières années presque 100 millions
mais cette année même aussi il y a eu
des annonces qui ont été faites environ
42 millions de dollars en nouvelle
contribution pour la PNH on essaie
d'encourager d'autres pays à faire
demain parce que pour nous la solution
durable au problème de sécurité en Haïti
c'est le renforcement de la Police
nationale d'Haïti la solution c'est la
police nationale c'est pas une force
d'intervention comme le demande Arielle
Henry comme comme l'évoque les Nations
Unies présentement la demande est assez
récente a été formulée par le Premier
ministre Henri la semaine dernière le
secrétaire général des Nations unies
émis une lettre aussi aux membres du
Conseil de sécurité à cet effet la fin
de semaine dernière il faudra voir on
est en train de nous le Canada les
États-Unis en France les autres pays
d'étudier cette demande-là ça fera
l'objet de discussion demain au Conseil
de sécurité à New York il va falloir
voir qu'est-ce qui te proposer
exactement je pense qu'il faut apprendre
du passé il y a eu beaucoup
d'interventions étrangères en Haïti donc
je pense qu'il faut prendre ces
décisions là en considérant ce qui a
fonctionné est-ce qu'il y a pas
fonctionné par le passé les
interventions passées ont clairement pas
complètement fonctionné parce que à
partir du moment où les forces
étrangères sortir on a l'impression que
la situation s'écroule de nouveau
absolument ce qui est pas été fait dans
les interventions précédentes c'est un
travail au niveau
de sanctions sanction pour non seulement
les gains un chef de gang sanctionné ça
pas beaucoup d'effets mais vous aurez vu
les déclarations du Premier Trudeau à
New York il y a trois semaines et de la
ministre jolie aliment la semaine
dernière dans ces déclarations les
discussions assez réunions là qui ont
été présidées par le Premier ministre et
la ministre ce qui a été discuté c'est
des sanctions pour non seulement les
chefs de guerre mais ceux qui facilite
leur travail ceux qui les soutiennent
ceux qui les finances donc il y a toute
une infrastructure il y a tout un
constellation d'acteurs
docteur économique corrompu ça veut dire
aller à l'extérieur d'Haïti absolument
donc le propre principal problème
d'Haïti c'est l'impunité et la grande
corruption pour s'attaquer à ce problème
là effectivement il faut du travail à
l'interne mais nous ce qu'on peut faire
en tant que Canada je pense que d'autres
pays comme les États-Unis peuvent faire
la même chose c'est de commencer à
s'attaquer à l'impunité à partir de
l'extérieur vers l'intérieur je précise
cependant que c'est pas tous les acteurs
économiques qui sont corrompus et c'est
pas tous les acteurs politiques qui sont
corrompus non plus il y a des gens en
Haïti qui veulent réellement développer
leur pays et construire un Haïti
meilleur dont nous rêvons tous mais il y
a des gens qui n'ont pas ces nobles
intentions là donc ce qu'il faut faire
comme communauté internationale c'est
s'attaquer à ce problème là ça aussi ça
va être discuté demain au Conseil de
sécurité
entamée par le Premier ministre Trudeau
il y a deux semaines à New York et nous
le cadence ensuite on va prendre des
mesures nécessaires pour mettre en des
décisions qui vont être prises par les
Nations Unies cette semaine deux
éléments là-dedans commençons par les
sanctions parce que vous l'évoquez
d'aller sévir à l'endroit de la sortie
Saint-Étienne ou de gens qui financent
les gangs de rue à l'extérieur de
l'extérieur d'Haïti ça veut dire ça veut
dire aux États-Unis où il y a une grosse
diaspora haïtienne ça veut dire aussi au
Canada oui ça veut dire aussi au Canada
donc il y a probablement des
ramifications
au Canada c'est un travail extrêmement
complexe un travail extrêmement sérieux
en Haïti beaucoup de gens disent où est
la liste où est la liste c'est pas des
choses qu'on peut faire facilement un
processus juridique très rigoureux à
suivre la première étape c'est la mise
en place d'un régime de sanctions par le
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
ensuite au Canada on a la loi sur les
Nations Unies cette loi-là oblige le
Canada à mettre en œuvre toute sanction
qui est adoptée par le Conseil de
sécurité à quel point c'est un gros
élément de la solution d'après vous pour
moi c'est l'élément fondamental sur le
long terme il faut éliminer de
l'équation des intérêts économiques
puissants et corrompus qui viennent
corrompre l'économie haïtienne le
système politique et qui finance aussi
de la violence et qui empêche le pays
d'avancer et dans votre tête c'est clair
qu'il y a des gens ici au Canada qui
sera ciblés par ces sanctions là je peux
pas l'affirmer clairement parce que le
travail juridique d'enquête pas encore
été fait mais je serai pas du tout
surpris quand même
force d'intervention là on en parle
beaucoup ça semble pas être la solution
que le Canada préconise ou favorise les
gens qui se souviennent un peu de la
dernière mouture c'est des militaires
d'un peu partout à travers le monde qui
sont pointés là qui ont été là pendant
une période de 10 ans pratiquement un
peu moins de 10 ans je crois
c'est quoi la différence maintenant
comment comment on devrait envisager moi
je pense qu'il faut peut-être découper
la situation au moins en deux sinon en
trois donc le blocage du terminal vaeux
pour moi c'est c'est la phase 1 ça c'est
l'approvisionnement naissance
70% de l'approvisionnement naissance du
pays et 100% ou presque de
l'approvisionnement du de la capitale
rentre depuis sa terminale pétrolier qui
qui sous le bord de la mer à
Port-au-Prince donc ça il faut débloquer
ça ça c'est la court terme débloquer ça
pour que le pays puissent recommencer à
tourner un peu le moyen terme pour moi
il s'agit de voir comment on peut mieux
appuyer la PNH ça peut être un appui
financier ça peut être un appui un
équipement ça peut être un appui
logistique ça peut être des formateurs
ça peut ça peut prendre toutes sortes de
formes pour stabiliser le pays et puis à
long terme comment on continue
d'accompagner la PNL pour s'assurer
qu'on va pouvoir créer des conditions
favorables un retour de la démocratie et
ça ça doit s'accompagner dans le
dialogue politique qui était rompu
depuis une dizaine de jours entre les
principales factions qui veulent
contrôler le pouvoir et la transition
mais qui pourrait reprendre aussi
rapidement qu'il auront pu la PNH qui
est de faire de l'anse des solutions
pour vous en tout cas pour le Canada
quand on regarde de ce côté-ci on a
l'impression que ça a bien été par
moment ça a pas très bien été par moment
est-ce que ça fonctionne l'argent et le
temps et les ressources qu'on investit
là-dedans je pense que oui on a vu
effectivement il y a eu des hauts et des
bas vous savez la coopération canadienne
en général mais en particulier avec la
PN j'ai beaucoup d'argent sur beaucoup
d'années on a eu des succès et on a eu
des uns succès c'est tout à fait normal
qu'on a un programme de cette ampleur
moi ce que je vois c'est une PNH avec un
noyau dur qui continue de tenir le fort
une pnache qui était puisée par ailleurs
une PNH qui est mal équipée donc c'est
pourquoi on encourage d'autres pays
d'autres acteurs à nous suivre dans
notre appui à la PNH on a un bon un bon
fond sur lequel on peut continuer à
construire
Sébastien carrière ambassadeur du Canada
merci beaucoup merci à vous